started the last game of the group stage
Hikaru Nakamura against Magnus Carson
there couldn't be in any other move than
the orangutan with B4 Magnus has already
done it to Hikaru and Hikaru does it to
Magnus what is your take on this news we
thought that it was not the scariest of
moves because of the reply B5
exactly like and Magnus goes B6
but B6 also makes a lot of sense because
if the most natural mode now is C4 then
we can still play C5 and this we have
discussed actually a bit then we
transpose to this in general we are we
are quite happy for black in this kind
of Hedgehog
style positions
so Basics is very logical but now comes
that also I was very surprised though
Hikaru plays F4
and look at this Evolution bar after
move 2 claims that black is better I
mean whatever Magnus has done in the
first game with white yeah he got worse
in two moves according to Evolution bar
so it's very funny again he's worse yeah
but but to be honest I mean can you
please explain me how do you play F4
here
I mean I'm shocked he wants to put this
sort of uh Birds opening or whatever
this bishop on A1 he wants to make it
strong so he plays F4 and tries to get
E3 and wow look at that C5 now computer
goes crazy can can actually black just
grab on F4 Queen takes F4 looks
excellent
I mean it doesn't look like a king's
Gambit at all yeah wow I mean okay and
this bishop on d8 will come to B6 yeah
yeah
and look at yeah and Magnus takes on F4
yeah he just yeah
but it doesn't change that much him yeah
there was nothing else I I was actually
thinking that probably the queen moved
somewhere like G5 yeah I went like G5
yeah yeah just two yeah or F5 okay F5
makes sense not to run into any Knight
FC Temple he went to F5 actually he went
to F5 Okay C takes B6 will be played
or I don't know if you first play Bishop
F3 but let's say ah the trick is
I don't know billion but that's the the
key idea of Hikaru that if he he manages
to get a quick castles then then who
knows
yeah exactly like he he's quite a bit
ahead in development yeah and then he
says you know what yes you have This
brilliant Bishop on B6 but this is so
brilliant also with the pawns on D2 on
it exactly I'm controlling them with
pondy to pawn E3 but now Magnus starts
his thing yeah
ah now GC wasn't played it wasn't played
Bishop F3 was played Bishop FC and then
H5 H5
yeah this is unpleasant okay First
bishop a locate was taken and Knight GC
yeah it's a little bit strange yeah that
why not Knight is the first and then
take exactly okay it probably doesn't
matter it probably doesn't matter but
still you give little bit less options
for your opponent yeah now the D5 Square
for instance is available exactly yeah I
doubt that G4
actually maybe then uh
short Castle played got Castle player
wow that that was a lovely tap yeah that
that's why Hikaru invited yeah maybe
maybe but okay
takes more to trick than well Champion
okay but e-cig now
something vulnerable pieces yeah isn't
it a little bit off here for black let's
say I play C4
but I don't know yeah suddenly very
scary for Magnus
he wants also also some Knight D3 and
then some look at four but okay hika who
goes Knight FC he he doesn't use his
momentum yeah that's a bit uh looks a
little bit lazy but after H4 he wants
Knight E5
so F6
yeah it's so because you're right now
normally when you play you realize so
much on pattern recognition and
typically exactly and so on you actually
have to think much more when you play
this
now it looks completely uh fine at least
yeah
most probably 24 yeah yes I'm not maybe
he doesn't want to but it's only because
H3 will come otherwise right yeah you
just don't want to give any kind of
player yeah I was just starting to doubt
if there actually is that much counter
play but uh
yeah I mean 24 is it so natural yeah
like of course you you wanted Queen E4
for quite some time already
extend okay the mustache starts yeah I
mean suddenly one can claim that
this Pawn structure is is clearly
preferable
white has white has this lovely Knight
on e4 Bishop on A1 yes it's great for
Magnus that he has this G7 F6 Pawn
structure but he's King and and his
pieces are still passive they're a bit
stupid currently huh yeah
Knight G6
um Knight G6 I mean I'm a little bit
surprised by Knight G6 honestly I guess
his idea is that if he plays C5 then the
Knight quickly reaches D5 or C6 but I
mean I'm a little bit more
this bishop probably goes to yeah C5 on
the board will go to A5
now we will go to C7 but on A5 what am I
I mean I'm not really no but I mean okay
then please make a move yeah I mean I
say yeah I'm very happily passing it to
you
yeah Bishop C7 played yes C6 because C6
yeah this is D6 uh is very softer Knight
D4 I mean the Knight D4 Knight B5 D5
same story Knight C5 comes immediately
that's why I was so surprised by Knight
on G6 yeah that denied uh on f8 yeah you
would be kind of protecting my structure
but did he play C6 already yeah he did
place not yet not yet he took it he took
it
c6d takes
c66 on the board yeah okay C6
sometimes we are getting the moves a bit
late uh no he didn't take it
he didn't did he play Knight D4 actually
if I say correctly ah that after DTX C6
he did not take on C6 yeah he played 94
I think if I'm seeing in the things
correctly you have eagle eyes yeah
that's that's good I I can appreciate
because I hardly see anything so I know
how good it is to see I mean it did not
come with age or something during
pandemic maybe because you were suddenly
I had collapsed when I was 15
.
it's bad monitors yeah and yeah in those
days the monitors were much worse
exactly yeah those old monitors killed
my eyes yeah
it's very nice yeah after E5 he doesn't
of course take the pawn on C6 but he
goes to F5 he goes Knight F5 yeah he
wants to take away with the Rook later
on I mean showing uh timanda's style
also yeah yeah the knights are looking
very nice yeah and Magnus goes Bishop d8
of the area very tight
he wants to be super tight here and this
has to be traded somehow I guess you
take because you want to bring the other
Rook here Rook B1 let's say and also now
the bishop is stupid they should be
stupid I mean the bishop would be lovely
on B6 now yeah but okay then then
already some bluish Tendencies are
coming yeah sure but still the foreign
immediately
yeah I immediately immediately he's not
taking on C6 he wants to take again with
the Knight or what
or with the bishop yeah but then after
97
I don't know what is his point because
if he anyway intends to take with the
Rook he might as well have done it
immediately I guess looks old it's a
past Pawn but yeah but somehow it feels
period yeah takes he took with the
bishop here
97 played yeah this is very logical yeah
I mean it had to be an idea actually oh
of course yeah Hikaru of course takes
and this is what we love Yeah 19 G7
vamos vamos exactly huh wow okay I feel
immediately my blood's circulating yeah
yeah exactly yeah now it takes F6 Born
to Be Alive
that's uh I mean now also Magnus needs
to stay alive again he needs to stay
alive I guess it's pretty uh
pretty depressing to uh to just take on
F6 and play these two pieces because H4
will be dropping yeah yeah well King G6
on the board he had Knight D7 will be
played I'm pretty sure that's kind of
the main idea Rook H5 hook H5 and Sun
mate Knight f8 and then Rook F7 oh oh
this is looking very scary can't say I
see you see them at yet but I see some
yeah but I mean these pieces are packed
yeah it doesn't look look correct let's
say yeah very very intelligent way after
Knight D7 yeah I mean Bishop B6 is
trying to get out let's say he has to be
solid but you are definitely worse after
Bishop but I mean visual B6 I think
Knight B6
so but you have many other scary options
here yeah I have so many options I mean
and yeah look G8 played I played yeah
yeah it played yeah I think you have to
eliminate this Knight when it reaches f8
yeah and I mean I would like to ask uh
so this can you just uh point out to us
that is the evolution bar still working
and if you have 95 check yeah this we
didn't discuss at all but it's of course
one of the most yeah it was it was a
movie very natural moves yeah just that
this Knight on D7 was so nice yeah that
yeah it was tricky huh yeah it was very
sometimes when you take the pawn on C6
you can enter with the Rook as well yeah
King H7
Knight 66 yes
okay but knight xc6 uh Luke pick C6 do
you have time for no Bishop B6 Suzuki F7
check 97 Knight G7
G6
[Music]
Rook F7 check bleeds doubt he simply
wants to trade and take on H7 and Royal
you think so yeah that okay what else
after King H6 you want to go back with
the Rook
no no I'm still digesting the the last
couple of moves
yeah yeah because I mean I was so scared
but apparently I was exaggerating yeah
who didn't find uh no I don't know it
could also be that he missed some
options
let's just highlight this this is
beautiful trick yeah this room text is
this geometry that everything is hanging
at the same time yeah but I mean I can't
take on A7
oops Yeah you can okay things escalated
ah so all this happened actually it
happened yeah G6 Luke A7 look takes C6
you look at it and Rook D6
a rook D6 is a bit unpleasant to to play
and you really want to go active but
yeah this in general is quite large but
why not I I guess you play A4 A5 yeah
and just push
I would really love to to eliminate this
no a49 C7 played Knight C7 yeah I was
about to say because
you get actually you kick him yeah you
have to choose now if you want to go
on the a file or or you want to not
support your iPhone now these guys are
defending these type of positions yeah
because yeah that's impressive you
usually for for me basically as long as
I feel you know that everything is
logical and I understand why things are
happening I can find Brilliant moves I
can find billion defenses everything but
okay first of all what is white thing A5
or something else is it a596 Bishop B6
that is the ID or yeah kind of that that
was a very logical sequence but I don't
know maybe A5 then Knight E6 comes
yeah it will be seven so basically yeah
he he wants to make sure that A5 Bishop
B6 that this blockade will not happen
Bishop FC Bishop B6 but it's already a
little bit strange
Rook C6 played however interesting I
mean this looks like a little bit like
an empty move
ah but okay yeah because I wanted to see
what happens then Magnus probably just
wants to give a check and get the look
behind
um he loses the bishop no this you
cannot do at least you can't do but then
what is he what is he aiming for with
this look C6 uh maybe bishop F6 yeah
this is the bishop B6 I was trying to
get Knight C5 to work but
not sure because you simply give check
and push upon well I was also thinking
about two B6 Bishop C7 played Bishop C7
played ah that was the idea this is very
clever yeah
applying to lock down this Rook Look
Down The Rook I mean also it's a sort of
clarifying situation on the Kingston
medifying the city and also eliminating
this age to pawn yeah this is super glad
then okay now 986 look C6 Bishop C7 what
a Harmony what Harmony he he opted for
it yeah Bishop takes his two on the
board yeah that makes so much sense huh
you look Basics yeah basically feels
like a blue but it's a draw foreign yeah
thick sticks
computer does not agree yeah I mean okay
but I mean okay it's too little
materials right so foreign
it would be just some incredible
study-like position if this would be a
real winning attempt yeah
yeah it's not even an attempt yeah it's
simply an immediate rule
still trying to incredible entertainment
Factor but from the semi-finals I think
the players will be much more cautious
yeah yeah Knight C5
after A5 Bishop E1 is coming
we just eliminate
yeah A5 plate can we just go Bishop E1
yeah Bishop E1 makes sense just not play
Knight B7 to force the draw Next
Movement exactly yes
even goes Bishop F2 yeah targets targets
the bishop yeah just to highlight that
yeah Knight B7 would run into this A6
strap typical A6 trap yeah the the
Knight on B7 can't fight the a pawn yeah
yep okay Bishop F2
yeah E4 played
Euphoria E4 Palladium Knight takes E4 I
guess
makes a lot of sense and then A6 or
Bishop A6 probably yeah okay it doesn't
matter yeah it doesn't matter yeah it's
the the game is gone already you give
one night for the one pawn and Bishop
for the other yeah
King F3 king of evolution bar is
trolling us or King Epstein I did
yeah
step into something
what is this King F3 I mean why why did
Magnus let this happen
yeah King FC on the board yeah Magnus
goes
Bishop C7 King D7 Bishop C7 King D7
yeah Bishop C7
um
King D7
has to be played and okay once the the
king is close to a pawn then okay Bishop
F4 but okay yeah then Bishop E1 and E1
but then A6 hang on A6 King C6 King
takes E4 King B6 King B6
what is this some margin still is there
right
yeah there is some margin but
but there is also a big question why we
are witnessing all of this yeah exactly
I mean this is
should be enough
yeah it's definitely enough the pawn is
not yet far Advanced yeah Bishop F4
Bishop E1 A6 on the board
we will be seeing this this line
but it looks like he might have missed
it yeah that he he survived this
for King B6 uh-huh
what else King F5 King G4 Bishop it's
hard to improve on this line yeah yeah
it's very difficult to improve I mean
black can try to push HD but I did not
feel that I should push this actually no
I was thinking that it gives it makes it
much easier for white yet to push the
pawn if it's exactly and you also win
time I I don't want no dig this pawn and
start running as quickly as possible
start running as quickly as possible
yeah I mean okay already then this is
the best what you
yeah
you can get Bishop D2 in order to
already be ready for G4 g5s and then
okay Bishop G5 yeah you won't be able to
push G5 yeah no the king is coming yeah
he actually opted for this bishop easily
yeah that's what I that but that's what
I was thinking like now King B7 Bishop
F2 he utilize your finesse but text
takes H3 you play G4 yeah that's a bit
tricky or you click no G3 sorry G3 no
but in general I don't want to treat
Bishops I I feel like okay let's say yes
to show I'm completely exhausted I don't
trust myself I mean I trust myself
running with the king with the bishop
but
so what is your line I mean let's say
you go somewhere with the King to be
five or B7 I mean you you take
responsibility for this maybe five
Bishop have two takes takes King C6
let's say
yes King FC okay no but yeah King F3 I
play eighteen FC HD yeah so King I have
to go pg-1 King G1
now with h33 very important
yeah Magnus opted for HD immediately
that's why you should go to C5 I'm sorry
I you should go to now you have King D4
King H2 King E3 yes yes of course no
yeah you can so then it's basically a
drawer
he goes H3 immediately
and just to highlight that this is
because the bluish method because H3
takes King B7
we should have to know you take and King
C6 yeah that's smart to go H3 before the
bishop trade yes yes that's why he had
to try to G4 he gonna go Bishop H4 I'm
guessing yeah
I mean he's on this uh Fortress it's one
of many good moves I would say yeah yeah
but I mean okay it's the stylish one
yeah yeah Bishop H4 makes a lot of sense
and claim enough is enough yeah and I'm
holding this
now you can lean back yeah that's it now
you can lean back
finally Magnus can lean back
he takes the bishop in the end yeah and
the handshake comes
yep
wow